i do it with everyone black and white
what young and old say
straight and lgbtq but
so people who i meet on the street yeah
yeah that's not good andrew cuomo under
fire not for killing all the
elderly people in new york and then
covering it up but because the man
apparently cannot keep his hands off
other people's asses apparently this is
like the big thing over there right now
now you'll recall
that the current president of the united
states joe biden said in an interview
back in march
that if the allegations against andrew
cuomo were confirmed that he should
resign
and here is joe biden saying just that
if the investigation confirms
the claims of the women should he resign
yes
i think he probably ended up being
prosecuted too
and well now it has been confirmed that
this is precisely what andrew cuomo
did according to attorney general
leticia james who herself
i will say has her eye on the
gubernatorial seat i mean it's pretty
obvious that leticia james wants to run
for governor
this is part of the problem with having
an ag with her eye on that top seed is
like
they get you in the crosshairs and it
can get real ugly real fast but
it's pretty obvious from i mean the
report on andrew cuomo's penchant
for ask rabbery is um 168 pages long
so that is a lot of buttocks grabbed
that is a lot of body parts groped
according
to the report the direct contact with
intimate body parts including the
touching of executive assistant number
one's breast
the grabbing and touching of the butts
of various women including executive
assistant number one and state entity
employee number one
and the governor's touching of trooper
number one's stomach and back
unquestionably amounted to sexual
harassment
in fact the law provides that direct
contact with an intimate body part
constitutes
one of the most severe forms of sexual
harassment the governor denies her
states he does not recall any of these
allegations of physical contact
but we find that the credible evidence
establishes that the governor in fact
touched these complainants in the way
they have described
those incidents amount to conduct that
clearly constitutes sexual harassment
these are the findings of attorney
general leticia james elected democrat
second the governor's numerous comments
of a sexually suggestive nature
including discussions about age
differences in partners at the same time
as the governor asked about finding a
girlfriend
miss bennett and trooper number one the
criteria for the girlfriend being
someone who can
handle pain trooper number one and
experiences with and views about
monogamy
whether an employee had been with an
older man feeling lonely and wanting to
be touched
the attractiveness of the employee and
comparing her to an ex-girlfriend
wanting to go out with two assistants
and calling them mingle mamas
whether an aide would be willing to
cheat on her partner playing strip poker
putting a tattoo on the butt as opposed
to the shoulder and locations of
piercings other than the ears
individually and collectively constitute
unlawful sexual harassment
this is according to letitia james again
democrat we find these comments
some of which the governor denied other
of which he claimed were merely
misrepresented
to be by any reasonable measure
gender-based offensive and harassing
the law provides the comments such as
these you not have been overtly sexual
or motivated by sexual desire okay first
of all it is important to point out here
that sexual harassment law is super
duper vague particularly in states like
california and new york
so making a joke at the office can
easily be construed as sexual harassment
however it seems that uh
andrew cuomo had the unfortunate pension
for um
for saying all these sexually suggestive
things to aids
and randoms that he met like over and
over and over again the law is clear
these types of sexually suggestive
comments if made as a joke or otherwise
particularly when part of a pattern of
comments in conduct as it was with the
governor
constitute unlawful sexual harassment
the complainant's not surprisingly said
that these types of suggestive comments
made them feel
uncomfortable humiliated unsettled taken
advantage of uncomfortable and creeped
out
for the recipients of these
inappropriate comments and jokes from
the governor we find the governor indeed
created a hostile work environment uh
wait there's more third
we find that under the totality of the
circumstances even the governor's less
overtly sexual comments that were
nonetheless gender-based
also created a hostile work environment
although the governor and certain of his
senior staff sought to downplay what the
evidence has revealed as frequent
gender-based comments and conduct by the
governor as simply old-fashioned or
cultural
neither explains nor justifies his
behavior nor makes it non-harassing
for example referring to female staff as
honey sweetheart and darling
kissing staff members on the forehead
and some of the senior staff on the lips
holding them tightly around the waist
for pictures in other occasions allowing
senior staff members to sit on his lap
at official functions
and lying down with his head on the
laugh of staff members who are women
we find based on our interviews with
numerous executive chamber employees did
in fact create a hostile work
environment for many staff who were
women okay yeah the last ones i'm gonna
go with yeah that's weird okay
like if you got a guy who's 60 and he
says to women honey or sweetheart
i i don't think that that's like the end
of the world i know too many 65 year old
guys
who address everyone that way and also
address like pretty much anyone who's of
a younger generation that way because
they've been used to calling their kids
that that doesn't sound like andrew
cuomo here
and andrew cuomo i think it's a fairly
good bet that when you take your head
and put it in the lap
of a female employee that what
say in the but
so yeah yeah that's not good
as a matter of law claiming that the
gender-based behavior is simply a
function of being old-fashioned or
culturally more affectionate
is not a defense to sexual harassment
one of his employees named
miss liss experienced the work
environment saying for whatever reason
in his office the rules were different
it was just you should view it as a
compliment if the governor finds you
aesthetically pleasing enough
so even though it was strange and
uncomfortable and technically not
permissible in a typical workplace
environment
i was in this mindset that it was the
twilight zone and the typical rules did
not apply
what these witnesses and many others
described as not just old-fashioned
affectionate behavior
it was sexual harassment says the
laticia james report
apparently they also found that the
executive chamber failed to report and
investigate allegations of sexual
harassment this violated
their own internal policies according to
the report
like people made reports these were not
investigated or followed up
upon so that is a serious problem here
is the thing though
so latisha james says i don't know about
the whole like prosecution of this thing
i mean you know not really by the way
they also found unlawful retaliation
right this report concludes that the
executive chamber meaning cuomo
engaged in prohibited retaliation
against lindsay boylan
in response to the allegation she made
on december 13 2020 that the governor
had sexually harassed her
a lawful retaliation occurs when the
employer takes an adverse action against
an employee or former
employee because that person made a good
faith complaint formal or informal of
unlawful discrimination
or harassment we find this occurred with
respect to lindsey boylan
as detailed above the incidents boiling
described in her medium article and her
testimony have been
admitted and corroborated as well so he
engaged in a cover-up
and the original activity he engaged in
an
unwillingness to even investigate so the
governor's office did not investigate
however according to letitia james they
are
they have no real feelings on whether a
prosecution should
take place which uh is is a real cop out
here by latisha james obviously like the
fact that she
is is not pushing forward with any sort
of
criminal prosecution is fairly
incredible
but that is where things stand so now
the question is does he live this down
does he live this down and the answer is
probably
because if there's one thing that we
have learned at this point it's if you
don't leave no one can make you
first i want you to know directly from
me
that i never touched anyone
inappropriately
or made inappropriate sexual advances
i am 63 years old i've lived
my entire adult life in public view
that is just not who i am
and that's not who i have ever been so
are democrats in the state legislature
actually going to throw him overboard
are they actually going to toss him i
have serious doubts
i don't think so i think he's going to
stick around and then he's going to hope
that
people forget about this because they
did the first time right these
allegations have been out there for a
very long time
everybody has known that andrew cuomo
engages in this sort of behavior for
years
on end apparently if you just wait long
enough it goes away
there is another complaint i want to
address from a woman in my office who
said that i groped her in my home office
let me be clear that never happened
she wants anonymity and i respect that
so i am limited but what i can say
but her lawyer has suggested that she
will file a legal claim
for damages that will be decided in a
court of law
trial by newspaper or biased reviews
are not the way to find the facts in
this matter
and and i will say i'm astonished i i
continue to be astonished
that cnn maintains ties with chris cuomo
okay there is a there is a report
appendix it
includes charlotte bennett's text about
her interactions with andrew cuomo and
an email from chris cuomo appearing to
draft a statement on behalf of his
brother so apparently chris
helped his brother draft a statement
responding to the allegations quote
questions have been raised about some of
my past interactions with people in the
office
i spent most of my time at work and
colleagues are often personal friends i
never intended to offend anyone or cause
any harm
sometimes i'm playful and make jokes
you've seen me do it at briefings
hundreds of times
my only desire is to add some levity and
banter to what is a very serious
business
i now understand my interactions may
have been insensitive or too personal
and some of my comments given my
position made others feel in ways i
never intended i'm sorry and feel deeply
embarrassed about that separately
my office has heard anecdotally some
people have reached out to ms bennett to
express his pleasure
about her coming forward my message to
anyone doing this is you have misjudged
what matters to me in my administration
you should stop now period this is a
statement apparently drafted
by chris cuomo on behalf of his brother
who at the exact time was um
the the the was covering his brother
uncovered
you'll recall in the middle of this
right it's it's
pretty amazing stuff so cnn has
like zero credibility at this point
frankly when it comes to covering these
sorts of issues
it is a shame for the cnn reporters who
don't suck uh but the fact that chris
cuomo gets to
go out there and pretend to be a moral
better for everybody uh
continues to befuddle to say the very
least
so that that is where things stand i
think that he probably outlives this
because that is the rule in american
politics these days it is that you
basically it's not that you live that
you die as a hero or live long enough to
become the villain it's that you
die as a hero live long enough to become
the villain
or live even longer and then become the
hero again
which i think will eventually happen
with andrew cuomo i wouldn't be
surprised if andrew cuomo pushes
statewide lockdowns as a result of this
it's wag the covet mask i would not be
surprised
at all if new york kicks into high gear
with regard to kobet just so we can go
back to andrew cuomo giving briefings
about how necessary he is
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right
you should but first like and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video